hello welcome to another one of my dr
sadler chalk and talk installments this
time i am responding to a set of
questions that were sent to me uh
through a different channel that i i've
usually gotten them most of them so far
been through vu however this one
actually came in response to one of my
talk and talk videos
number three where i talked about
teaching religion in public schools and
how that could be allowable and what
clarifications have to be made
so somebody asked me
do you have any advice for when students
may perhaps have approached you as to
which religion is true
and if so did they persist more than
once and then they follow this up by
asking as teachers are we permitted to
refer them to textual sources that may
or may not be academic
so these are some really good and
important questions
and i wanted to address this in this
follow-up and i think i can actually get
both of these in we're
already one minute in and see if i can
get it in in under 15 minutes
so basically what we're looking for here
is advice for when students ask the
inevitable question
which religion is true
and if you think about it
even if we've adopted the religious
studies model why are we teaching about
religion why are we
investigating these things why are we
introducing students to these well
because religions are bodies of belief
practices communities
historical narratives that people
throughout time have considered not only
to be true but to be transcendently true
to be
teaching them about
what is you might say absolutely true
not merely relatively true but but true
in the deepest sense so it's it's
inevitable that this question will come
up and i think the key thing to do is to
turn it into a set of teachable moments
and i've got a little bit of advice for
how to do that
the first thing
i would suggest is asking
this
set of questions
true
well in what sense is do we mean
this do we mean
that by saying that one religion is true
that it is most correct about god or the
nature of the divine or the gods or
you know
an economy of the divine or who knows
there's a lot of different
possibilities there
every religion has not only origin
stories but also
a number of teachings about
the nature of human beings
what are they made of what do they
return to
um how do they tie in with the divine
are they made for example in god's image
as
you find in judaism and christianity
what does that actually mean you know to
be made in god's image
somebody like thomas aquinas would say
it's primarily through our function of
reason a philosopher like rene descartes
said through having an unlimited will
clement of alexandria actually connected
it to music
in a beautiful piece said that
we in that we sing and that we produce
music are most like the divine so that's
those are things that uh religions talk
about and they could be more true or
less true right
the world or not just the world that we
we see but the entire world the cosmos
where did it come from where is it going
to
is it cyclical are there more worlds
than one those are things that religion
takes stance on life and death this is
really key
you know if you think about it where
does the rubber really meet the road for
some of the disagreements
think about the difference between three
basic stances
one stance could be
well
you live
you die
that's it
right the big sweep the dirt nap as they
call it
that's one position
other uh people say
well there's a good place and there's a
bad place they always you know the good
places above
and if you're more or less good you wind
up in a good place or you know if god
takes mercy on you or something like
that and if you're bad you end up in a
bad place and the bad thing is once
you're in the bad place you're not
getting down but the consolation is if
you make it into the good place you're
staying there too
or could it be that it's that it's
cyclical
as in religions that believe in
reincarnation
could it be that there's
a whole system of merit
and
demerit so that what you do in a
previous life affects where you go
the next life through a variety of
mechanisms well those are different
positions
and those positions at least as far as
the ultimate truth of them
are not actually compatible
so
it's natural that people would ask about
this and want to know especially
young students they want to know you're
teaching us all about these different
religions which one is actually true get
them to ask about these things and then
get them to
think about other things
i have another set of things tied in
with with teachable moments
first i'd like to tell you about what i
did when i taught religious studies
at indiana state prison
i'm actually a roman catholic so i'm a
christian i belong to the roman catholic
church
i'll actually worship at a marine
catholic church in eastern right church
currently because i love the liturgy
i had to conceal my catholic identity
from my students when i was teaching in
the prison and there were several good
reasons why that was the case
i needed to
for one thing
i needed to
maintain a certain sort of reserve
in part because
there was already a lot of anti-catholic
prejudice
among some of the religious groups and
for me to be revealed as catholic would
have led to some of them saying you
can't possibly
teach in an unbiased way you're going to
be favoring your group
and that that could be a legitimate
concern because there may be
some cases where people are unable to
keep themselves from doing so
what i would point out to them
is that if i'm doing my job right as an
instructor of religious studies
then it should not matter
what
religious group i belong to what
traditions i have hold what my practices
are
other than which days i have to take off
or things like that
um but if i am actually doing my job
well
i'm not saying that this is this is
perfect
or that anybody can embody this and
never falter in this respect
if i'm doing my job well
then it shouldn't matter whether i am a
roman catholic christian an eastern
orthodox christian a lutheran christian
a pentecostal christian
you know it shouldn't matter whether i'm
a
sunni muslim a shiite muslim shouldn't
matter whether i'm a buddhist of this
school this school this school
i should be teaching about people's
religions
and treating them all in a fairly
sympathetic
way that also
has a certain reserve
where i don't commit myself
there was one other concern too i didn't
want people to know that i was catholic
because then the catholic students might
try to get over on me right they would
assume that their fellow co-religionists
would would be
doing them favors and i didn't want that
either it was really ironic too because
i had so many students there was a large
catholic presence
at
indiana state prison and i had so many
students from the catholic church
in my classes explaining to me
what a church doctrine was not knowing
that i was actually catholic and that i
was teaching cases class
on sunday mornings
that's
just you know what took place for me
i'm not saying that that has to be the
parenting
i think it's useful to teach students
about the various attitudes
that religious groups do take towards
truth
not only the truth of their
perspective but the truth of other
perspectives
and these are terms that we we typically
use in religious studies to talk about
these one of them is actually quite new
parallelism
an exclusivist says that they
have the absolute truth and everybody
else is basically wrong
except insofar as they coincide with
them
and some would go so far as to say
well even if you have any admixture of
error you're just completely wrong
some examples of exclusivists would be
christian fundamentalists
fundamentalists in the strict sense of
the term where it does not include
evangelicals but hardcore
fundamentalists
that would be an example of exclusivists
inclusivists believe that their faith is
the right faith is the truest faith but
that other
other traditions other faiths other
groups they are not completely wrong and
as a matter of fact they may be on the
right track sometimes without even
recognizing it or or believing it the
roman catholic church's doctrine on this
and the other older christian
churches as well so these are orthodox
coptics
all these other churches
that seems to be their
position um
sony muslims in so far as they their
view is that jews and christians are not
totally wrong as a matter of fact we're
the people of the book and we've gotten
some things right we just you know we
got mixed up about who that jesus guy
was or or you know the nature of the
torah and the
the covenant with humanity or who was
the first muslim or things like that
and were also mistaken about about
muhammad that would be
inclusivist
they're not saying you guys are
completely wrong they're saying
you are off on some things in certain
respects
a pluralist
would be somebody who is saying
something along the lines of
well they're all equally right
they just have different ways of getting
to the same basic place john hick would
be a great example of a classic
pluralist he made a lot of arguments for
that
to some degree you could see
hinduism
as practiced by by
many hindus as pluralist
as a matter of fact if you ask andrews
what do you think about that jesus guy
they will say yeah
some of them will say he's an avatar
you know one one face of god
some of them actually say that about
muhammad which tends to drive muslims
nuts
relativists
are going a little bit further than
pluralists they're saying well it's all
just up to the individual or the group
and whatever's right for them is right
for them and there's a little
incoherence in that position which i'm
not going to try to explore
and then there's an interesting new
way of thinking about this i'm not sure
it's radically new but to give it a name
and to single it out is kind of new and
they they speak of parallelism or being
a parallelist and the idea behind that
is
you're saying that um
the different
the different religions are not on the
same track to exactly the same truth
uh rather
you know the
christian is aiming for the trinitarian
christian god
and the
muslim is aiming for
you know eternal life with with allah
and paradise these are not exactly the
same this is a complicated issue i'm
going to actually close that off right
here
here's another thing to think about what
what truth claims can we or do we have
to make without endorsing when we're
teaching other studies there's quite a
few
when we are saying for example a
religion has a certain amount of
adherence that's a truth claim it's
either it's either correct or not and
what's not requiring us to be committed
to that religion in order to say that
if i say for example buddhists believe
in the four noble truths
and here is what they say the four noble
truths are i am making a truth claim but
again i am not committing myself to the
ultimate truth of
you know the four noble truths as being
religious doctrine
whether they're correct or not whether
the buddhists have all this stuff
correct
answer the question of recommending
texts this is kind of along the same
line that's why i've been heading to
this point if you're recommending a text
to a student what are you doing you're
providing them with resources to more
fully understand
what it is that you're talking about the
religions doctrines on all these things
so if i hand if a student asks me about
what do muslims believe
and i hand him or her
a copy of the koran or a hand a
collection of a hadith
that's not an academic book
i am not there by saying this is truth
this is absolutely correct
i am actually saying
this is what they believe this is
important to them you can study this
and i think that's completely
appropriate
so long as you're not endorsing it